Nos dicen: "Observa la siguiente recta numérica".
En esta recta numérica en realidad tenemos tiempo,
por lo que incluso podrías llamarla una recta
del tiempo: empezamos a la una en punto aquí,
luego vamos a 1:15, 1:30, 1:45, y luego a las
dos en punto; y dice "¿Qué momento del día se
muestra en la recta numérica?" Pausa este video
y ve si puedes resolverlo. Muy bien, entonces,
para la hora creo que es bastante sencillo. Ya
pasamos la una, pero estamos antes de las dos,
entonces sabemos que la hora será la una con
algo; no va a ser dos con algo porque todavía
no hemos llegado a las dos en punto. Ahora,
¿cuántos minutos son después de la una? Bueno,
tenemos una pista aquí: va a estar entre
15 y 30, ¿y dónde está exactamente? Bueno,
una forma de saberlo es que si miras estas
marcas parece que cada una representa un minuto,
sólo contemos: si comenzamos en 1 vamos a una,
0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14,
15, sí, parece que cada una de estas marcas
indica un minuto. Entonces sólo tenemos que
averiguar cuántas de estas marcas hemos pasado
a partir de 1:15, así que vamos de 15 a 16, 17,
18, 19, 20, 21, 22, 23, 24, 25; entonces
este punto representa la una y 25 minutos,
25 minutos después de la una. Otra forma en la
que podrías haber pensado es que cada una de
estas marcas de en medio representa 5 minutos,
y puedes contar: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, entonces son 5,
son otros 5, por lo que aquí tenemos 5 + 5
son 10, serán 10 minutos después de la 1:15;
bueno 15 + 10 son 25 otra vez, entonces el tiempo
que se muestra en la recta numérica es la 1:25.